Same product, same price,
same traffic.
One of these pages converts at 2%, the
other converts at 7%. That's not a small
difference. That's three and a half
times more revenue from the exact same
visitors.
So, what's different? [music]
It's not the product. It's not even the
offer. One page shows a product, the
other one sells it. It's guiding someone
from this looks interesting all the way
to I need this. Answering questions
before they're asked, removing doubts
before they form, building trust at
every single step. And every single
decision that creates that difference,
we're going to go through it right now.
Before the user even reads the product
name, their eyes hit a visual anchor. We
added a subtle but clear best-seller
badge right above the product title.
This uses the halo effect. By
immediately crowning the product with a
status badge, whether you choose
best-seller, new arrival, or top-rated,
you frame the user's entire perception
[music] of the product before they've
read a single detail. It instantly
elevates the item's perceived value.
Right next to that, we fixed a massive
missed opportunity with the imagery. The
original design features an isolated
product tub sitting on a plain empty
background. When you sell a physical
product online, the user can't pick it
up. They have to mentally bridge the gap
between that raw powder and the actual
experience of consuming it.
>> [music]
>> We call this the imagination gap. The
solution?
We updated the hero image to show the
tub right next to a freshly mixed icy
glass of the greens and some sliced
pineapple. The human brain processes
images infinitely faster than text.
We're answering the question, "What does
this actually look like?" instantly. By
making the product feel refreshing and
appetizing, we lower the cognitive
effort required to understand [music]
its value. Perfectly round numbers like
100, 200, or 500 subconsciously feel
like an estimate, a placeholder, or
worse, fake. We updated this to a highly
specific 4.9 stars and 221
reviews.
Specific numbers feel much more
authentic and believable to a shopper.
We also added a subtle fire icon with
the text 500 plus sold this week.
Instead of the user thinking, "Should I
be the first person to risk trying
this?" they think, "Wow, hundreds of
people are buying this right now. It
must be great." It's a powerful trust
anchor that naturally encourages them to
join the crowd. Next, let's look at how
users interact with the page [music] to
pick their flavor. The old design hid
the options inside a standard drop-down
menu. Drop-downs are often considered
lazy design because they force the user
to click, scroll, and read just [music]
to see what their basic options are. We
brought these options out into the open
using clear visual swatches with little
fruit icons. The user can [music]
instantly see their three choices
without doing any work. But we pushed
the UI further to solve a very specific
user fear. When buying a health drink,
the biggest question is, "What if this
tastes awful?" To ease [music] this
worry without cluttering our clean
layout, we added a helpful
micro-interaction.
>> [music]
>> When a user hovers over a flavor like
kiwi, a small tooltip smoothly appears
saying, "Light, [music] tart, and not
overly sweet." Good UX anticipates
questions and delivers reassuring
information at the exact moment of
hesitation.
At this point, you might be wondering,
"How do you know the best way to
actually improve a specific part of
design? How do you know which layouts
will get people to buy? [music] And
where do you even look for that
inspiration?"
The reality is, top designers don't rely
on gut feeling or try to reinvent the
wheel. We study what is already proven
to work at the highest level. And the
fastest way we do that is with Mobbin,
the sponsor of this video. Mobbin is our
ultimate design cheat code. It's a
massive library of the most successful
sites and apps on the planet. You can
search for shopping or health [music]
and instantly get inspired by top brands
like Seed or Hims. You get to see
exactly how they structure the pricing
cards, hero images, and trust elements
pixel by pixel. It basically hands you
the proven blueprint of what's
converting instead of having to guess.
If you want to stop designing in the
dark, design with absolute confidence,
and save hours on every project, hit the
first link in the description to check
out Mobbin and grab 20% off. Let's move
to the next section. This is the most
critical area of the entire screen. This
is where a great UX designer stops just
making things look nice and actively
increases a brand's average order value.
The original UI used standard stacked
radio buttons for one-time purchase
versus subscribe and save. Radio buttons
present two visually equal choices,
which usually causes users to default to
the lowest immediate risk, the one-time
purchase. We completely rebuilt this
using dynamic side-by-side selection
cards to create a much smoother flow. By
default, the subscribe card is selected.
It has a gently tinted background and
features a green most popular tag.
>> [music]
>> We are visually guiding the user toward
the best value option. To handle their
fear of getting locked into a contract,
we brought the reassuring details
directly inside the box. Save 15%,
cancel anytime, and priority dispatch.
We calm their financial worries at the
exact second they're making the
decision.
But what happens when the user does
click one-time purchase? We don't just
give up. The UI smoothly expands to
reveal tiered bundle options. A
one-month supply, a two-month supply
with 10% discount, and a three-month
supply with 20% discount. By using
progressive disclosure, we keep the
initial interface clean, but reward the
user's click with new money-saving
options. This gives the user total
autonomy while intelligently
incentivizing a larger upfront purchase.
If you enjoy this kind of thinking
behind UI design, the psychology, the
small interaction details, the way tiny
changes can completely change how people
[music] view your designs. This is
exactly what we break down inside the UI
UX Playbook. It's a practical guide
where we walk through real UI patterns
and explain why they work, how they
influence user decisions, and how you
can apply them in your own designs.
Because good design is rarely about
making something just look nice. It's
about understanding what the user is
thinking, [music]
where they might hesitate, and how small
design choices can guide them smoothly
through [music] an experience. If you
want to get better at spotting these
opportunities in your own work, you can
check out the UI UX Playbook at
uxpeak.com.
And as a small thank you for watching
the channel, you can use the code
playbook50 for a 15% discount. The link
is in the description if you'd like to
explore [music] it.
Finally, let's look at the button and
the trust badges underneath it. The
[music] original button simply says,
"Add to cart." followed by generic text
points. Free shipping, money back, made
in USA. Add to cart is purely
transactional language. It reminds the
user that they're about to spend money.
And generic badges like free shipping
don't build deep trust anymore because
shoppers expect [music] them. The
solution? We softened the primary button
copy to add to cart start my journey.
This subtle shift makes clicking feel
less like a purchase and more like a
positive step in their health routine.
Beneath that, we replaced the generic
text with custom illustrated icons
tailored to what a health-conscious
shopper actually cares about. 100%
vegan, a 60-day guarantee, and most
importantly, third-party tested for
heavy metals. We are actively answering
their unspoken questions about safety
and quality.
Now, let's take one last look at where
we started
and where we ended up.
It's a night and day difference, right?
>> [music]
>> I'm really curious to hear from you all.
Which of these changes do you think
moves the needle the most? Drop a
comment down below and let me know your
thoughts.